these days everyone's a critic so if
that's the case how awful must a movie
be to actually get a 0% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes there are bad movies and then
there are movies so terrible that
literally no one single reviewer in the
world liked them here's a look at some
of the truly horrible movies that earned
a 0% rating on Rotten Tomatoes a
thousand words starring Eddie Murphy the
comedy a thousand words was filmed back
in 2008 but it was so bad paramount
waited for entire years to release it
when your own studio doesn't want anyone
to see the film they paid to make you
know you have problems and critics
agreed that it was awful lambasted the
lame story about a guy who's cursed by a
magic tree it will die if he talks too
much one critic called the flop a poorly
conceived and startling Lee miscast
comedy that works to every one of its
stars weaknesses not good Bucky Larson
born to be a star every so often a movie
comes along that's so bad so random it's
hard to imagine how it was ever made in
the first place
Bucky Larson born to be a star is one of
those movies the film which starred Nick
Swardson as a dopey small-town grocery
bagger who moves to LA to follow his
parents pornstar footsteps opened in
2011 as some of the worst reviews
Hollywood had seen in decades many
critics trashed the film for its unfunny
childish jokes in fact reviews were so
harsh by the time the movie opened
Swardson slating man career was already
over a star was not born just happened
brain just buckle the Nutcracker in 3d
one of the most egregious offenders of
the post avatar 3d craze was 2010's
notoriously awful The Nutcracker in 3d
which took Tchaikovsky's ballet and
turned it into a bombastic musical
featuring Elle Fanning Nathan Lane and
not exactly subtle references to wait
for it the Holocaust worst of all the
movies over-the-top sets and CGI were
literal eyesores looking less like a
ballet and more like Michael Bay
ultimately Lou luminous
of the New York Post summed it up best
when he called the Nutcracker in 3d
spectacularly misconceived bloated and
incredibly ugly but tell us how you
really feel Lou super babies baby
geniuses to the original baby geniuses
with just one positive review away from
making this list that in itself is
enough reason to wonder how anyone on
earth allowed a sequel to happen and yet
somehow someway super babies baby
geniuses too rolled into theaters in
2004 unsurprisingly critics were quick
to call it out for being what it was a
dumb idea
Joanne Kauffman of The Wall Street
Journal called it unspeakably ghastly
and jr. Jones of the Chicago Reader said
it was excruciating well Christopher
Borelli of the Toledo Blade pretty much
summed up everyone's feeling when he
wrote I found this all profoundly
disturbing
Hey
undeterred producers turned the series
into a full-fledged franchise releasing
three more installments but the critics
just couldn't take any more none of the
subsequent baby geniuses even have
enough reviews to earn a spot on the
tomato meter one missed call the modern
revival of the horror movie genre has
led to a number of bad decisions in
Hollywood
like that time Paris Hilton co-starred
in a remake of House of Wax but the
worst of the bunch was the ridiculous
one missed call a remake of a 2003
Japanese horror movie that opened a
truly terrifying reviews in 2008 a
blatant ripoff of the far superior ring
films critics were quick to roll their
eyes at the film's premise which
essentially revolved around a cellphone
that killed people calling it contrived
silly and a complete waste of time and
those were the nicer reviews this is one
call you should be glad you missed
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]